la frc a le département de la réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la réunion nous
présente terre d'ici
pour
créée en juin 2012 larry fel
l'association réunionnaise
interprofessionnelle fruits et légumes
regroupe différents acteurs de cette
filière des producteurs bien entendu
représentés par leur coopérative mais
également des importateurs et grossistes
sans oublier des professionnels de la
transformation et des représentants de
la grande distribution avant des
réunions par thématique par produit et
donc nous nous rassemblons une fois par
mois une fois tous les deux mois ça
dépend de l'importance du sujet et on
discute bien entendu de ce que nos
productions de ce que des problèmes
rencontrés chez les uns et chez les
autres et on trouve ensemble une
solution pour apporter à la
problématique que nous rencontrons du
moment voilà travaillé ensemble par
l'action collective
l'objectif de la rive elle est de
développer améliorer et sécuriser une
offre de produits agricoles et
agroalimentaires sein de qualité et
adaptées aux besoins des consommateurs
réunionnais l'idée première c'est de
dire quand même il faut il faut avoir m
2 des produits de qualité en quantité de
façon régulière et bien sûr à un prix
qui est acceptable pour pour l'ensemble
des réunionnais donc c'est là aussi pour
nous la carte à jouer c'est à dire nous
gérons un peu plus de 100 références de
fruits et légumes à la réunion et donc
il est bien entendu que dans 100
références vous allez toujours à trouver
quelques petites références qui sont un
peu en retard de production
et là forcément il faut il faut mettre
tout le monde autour de la table pour
voir comment rapidement à trouver une
solution
jeunes agriculteurs giovanni bertil à
diversifier sa production de tomates en
se lançant dans la culture hors sol de
salades sous ses serres il en cultive
ainsi plusieurs variétés nouveau cultive
la batavia la salle batavia la batavia
rouge le
la feuille de chêne rouge aussi la
feuille de chêne verte et la mini
romaine mirinae romaine est très
apprécié dans les paniers fraîcheur de
vire adhérents de vivea une coopérative
de producteurs qui lui assure
l'écoulement de ces légumes bio vanille
peut ainsi se concentrer davantage sur
la production de son exploitation
maraîchère
on a pu se soucier de diaba demain on va
aller au marché voir ce qu'on peut
vendre
là on sait que la coopérative nous
comment nos salades et on va on va les
déposer
on a pas à dire à se dire bessalah
bonbons rester sur nos bras
automatiquement il recommande d'ailleurs
des salades pays de qualité dont une
partie sera conditionné par cette unité
de transformation saint pierroise
spécialisé dans la préparation de fruits
et de légumes de quatrième et cinquième
gamme et dépenseront pas ou quatre
personnes étaient lavés désinfecter
saurait et c'est à l'emploi
façonner le producteur a l'assurance de
pouvoir écouler son produit et mon
assurance de pouvoir être approvisionnés
donc c'est à peu près combien de tours
nous est réservé pour chaque produit à
chaque période
en fait c'est un bon partenariat oui ça
marche bien
producteur maraîcher à la plaine des
cafres alain dambreville cultive entre
autres de la tomate sous serre une
production hors sol pour laquelle alain
est toujours aux petits soins
c'est un travail ou et quotidien tous
les jours il faut être un peu dedans
si c'est pas c'est pas pâli ccc feuillet
et c'est apporter tous les soins qu'on
peut à la culture
si on apporte régulièrement des soins on
a moins de moins d'intrants à m que ce
soit des produits phytosanitaires ou
autre vous mieux vaut mieux intervenir
mécaniquement adhérents d'une
coopérative membres de l'interprofession
fruits et légumes
alain voit aujourd'hui tout l'intérêt de
faire partie d'une telle organisation
il ya des moments où on le marché est
pas bien organisée où et où tout le
monde a planté donc il va y avoir une
surproduction c'est là où c'est
important qui n'accueille qu'une
interprofession un endroit ont tout le
monde qu ensemble c'est où la profession
les agriculteurs et qu ensemble
le commerçant celui qui sahara qui
s'avance à celui qui met en marche et
les importateurs que vous allez là et
que ben incapable de 1 de se dire il
faut il faut pas qu'on ait des moments
de surproduction ou ce serait dramatique
qu'on jette de la tomate ou congé ddd
des fruits et légumes à la réunion c'est
important qu'on compte qu'on se concerte
et qu'on organise la production une
organisation de la filière fruits et
légumes ou les transformateurs ont
également un rôle important à jouer dans
cette entreprise de bras panon on
conditionne ainsi en boîte des tomates
pays les tomates sont réceptionnés sur
le matin ça vient des organisations de
producteurs qui avaient qui nous
souscrivons à l'année des contrats pour
la transformation réception le matin
puisque tension dans la foulée vous
allez voir le process en
et
c'était des approvisionnements réguliers
notamment pendant la période estivale on
va dire puisqu'on y verra beaucoup moins
pas de vue industriel il faut quand même
des quantités assez importantes
on ne peut pas transformer 2 min
quantité cela nous fait attention un
volume d'environ 10 tonnes de tomates
qu'on va traiter en 7 heures six heures
sept heures après la réception et la
pesée les tomates sont plongés dans un
bain à bulles pour les nettoyer après la
passe de lavage de triage
nous possédons un cubage dans des
dimensions qui correspond à ce que le
client souhaite
il finit pour l'utiliser dans la cuisine
réunionnaise
pour l'heure ces tomates pays emboîtent
sont destinés aux cuisines des
collectivités un marché porteur que les
responsables de l'ars eiffel compte bien
développer dans l'avenir
actuellement doit transformer un peu
moins de 5% de la production locale
nous ambitionnons bien sûr de d'évoluer
pour les dix prochaines années entre 20
et 33 sont donc mais c'est le cadre que
nous avons définies je crois que les
transformateurs nous attendent sur ce
terrain et nous mettons tout en oeuvre
en tout cas pour accélérer
m